putting salt on the mcgriddle that
that's ah i don't know the first what
are we doing eating mcgriddle since 2021
so that i want to start there uh jane
slater joins the show nfl network we saw
her on on hard knocks briefly we'll get
to her short cameo in a second do you
put salt on your mcgriddles jane
it's so california elitist of you to say
who eats mcgriddles these days
oh yeah
you're like we don't know where it came
from it's non-gno gmo or whatever in
texas we pretty much eat everything
processed i love salt that's going to be
the my downfall at one point so
i felt the kindred spirit to jerry uh
in that scene and particularly all the
f-bombs
i really have to watch myself even my
own family when i'm at home they always
say to me how do you use that word so
frequently and not say it on air and i
just say one day it's gonna split me up
a reminder jane the rich eisen show a
family show here on peacock westwood one
and siriusxm what's it like for you to
see your cowboys family now on tv for
the whole world to see you've been
around this team for for so long now we
get to see uh
these guys wrapping presents for each
other we get to see them catching puns
we get to see him in the locker room it
just gets the whole world gets a look in
to the dallas cowboys a team you've
covered for a long time
well i had a few takeaways and and to
your point of course i've watched hard
knocks over the years but it does hit a
little bit closer to home when
you know the cameras are in front of you
every day and they're shooting this but
you've also gotten to know a lot of
these guys off the field i love that
they started
with dak prescott uh because i think
fans got to see authentically
who he is in fact there's a person
working on a piece on dak prescott and
they reached out to me and they said
just for perspective is deck really as
likable as everybody says he is and i
said that's the crazy thing about him
you know i've covered plenty of
quarterbacks over the years and i think
they they get battle scars from dealing
with the media they sort of clam up
um they start to distrust people their
circles get smaller
that's not that guy i mean when i go and
do events with him or whether it be at
the football field or when i see him out
at dinner or in public in dallas what
you see is what you get and i think
that's what endeared him so quickly to
that locker room in 2016 and why it was
so easy
for jerry to hand the keys to the
franchise to him over a guy that
vacationed with the jones family in the
offseason so i appreciated that and i
also feel like
a lot of people just refuse to give
ezekiel elliott credit
for personal growth and getting and and
getting older and wiser
i'm glad i'm not judged on a lot of the
mistakes that i made when i was 20 21
and i'm glad there wasn't cell phone
videos back then quite frankly
and so when i've seen his maturation
over the years
and his playfulness and what he's like
away from the cameras because of so much
that he had to deal with early on in his
career as it related to the media and
scrutiny and
and you know everyone's observations and
you can say what you will about all of
that
but he is a very likable guy his
teammates absolutely love him and dak
and him truly do have this special bond
you know one has the two one uh as a
jersey number 21 the other is four and
then the area code in dallas is 214. so
it's always been this really and they're
just there's polar opposite you know
these two guys have completely different
personalities and they're sort of an
unlikely couple but it is just such an
authentic and pure friendship and
relationship and then like i said micah
parsons is one of these guys who
you never know what to make of the hype
train when it's especially with the
cowboys like it's really hard not to to
drink the kool-aid sometimes because of
the pr machine that is dallas but
micah parsons consistently makes plays
on the football field and there was all
of that stuff at penn state i talked to
a number of teams that just felt there
was a little too much there for them and
i pressed him on that you know his
introductory press conference and he
said look
that's behind him
there was an investigation into some of
some of the things that were related to
i would call it hazing on campus so to
speak
uh and he was ready to move forward and
since then
uh he really has just shown up and shown
out for this team every day in practice
he was only in for two series in the
pittsburgh game and had the fumble
recovery and i think three tackles and
then he saw on the show he just kept
wanting to play he just reminds me of
i don't know if you have siblings guys
but i have a younger sister she's six
years younger and
growing up she always wanted to play
with me and my friends so she'd always
come knock on the door and we'd slam the
door and you can't play with us
that kind of feels like micah sometimes
at practice like he's just so eager to
hang out with the veteran to be a part
of the group
i just wonder how that acclimation uh
going to take place but i think when
you're making plays and you're helping
the defense
win that side of the ball i think it's
going to be very easy for him to do that
co-host of the boys and girl podcast for
fox sports radio jane slater joins the
show jane yesterday when messi was
announced for psg the psg account on
instagram went up by 20 million
followers
did your follower account go up from
your cameo on hard knocks last night
i think someone said my head looked like
a twinkie because all you saw was like
blonde hair and it was like you know
this kind of cone shape and it was
taking up a third of the screen i i was
disappointed i did get an imdb credit so
jane's head will get you know its own
page uh but i was disappointed i asked
him of those questions and you know at
least give me a producer credit hard
knocks you know i'm putting a lot of
effort into
looking my tv best out there and uh
can't even can't even get a look out
there it's just tough out in these
streets
aj jade it's brockman uh you mentioned
dak prescott to start the episode i mean
kind of a jarring image of that scar uh
to begin to begin last night but how
about the revelation of the second
surgery was that really known among the
cowboys insiders
yes
uh i had learned about a second surgery
uh
about january and this surgery took
place towards the end of december now
there were different ways that it was
characterized back then we were told
that it was a second surgery that he
pushed himself
so hard in rehab that he hurt himself
and then others reported it as a clean
up surgery and so
you know it was hard to understand what
that surgery was but we knew there was a
second surgery uh tom pelicero and ian
rappaport ended up reporting that
i think it was in february or march
after you know we had all sort of
collectively done some digging on this
and then there was dallas radio station
in town 105 through the fan that really
went hard on this so there were people
talking about it but i don't think he
ever openly admitted
to the second surgery or the extent of
that surgery back then so it's hard to
say what what it was but if it was just
a clean up surgery then why didn't you
feel the need to bring it up i thought
that was interesting right and what
about the the lat issue the shoulder
how's that
working itself out right now
i thought it was interesting or so
walking you back through that day we saw
exactly what the hard knock cameras were
seeing you know we came out to practice
the day before i mean he was
he was a gunslinger out there and a lot
of us were shocked that even the ankle
wasn't heavily taped and he didn't
seem like he had any limitations but i
mean he was just i mean you saw it i
mean just
throwing that ball with you know
a lot of force and so i don't know if he
strained it
uh in that way he hasn't really said how
this muscle strain came to be
but he walked off the field it was like
sort of this innocuous injury nothing he
wasn't hit
uh it wasn't like he pulled up all of a
sudden and you know screamed in pain
and then we just see him walking off uh
with the training staff and
the local team reporters were supposed
to do an interview with them at two that
day
kept getting delayed and then there was
going to be a statement and i was
sitting there going well if it's just a
strain why do we need a statement right
so we had a form we had a former player
out there and i said just out of
curiosity would you guys take somebody
into town for like an mri or something
if there was like concerns that they
said absolutely
and so sure enough around 5 30 we get
this press release that says there's
this latissimus muscle strain um
and
we're not worried about it we're just
going to be careful with it but then we
haven't seen him throwing like a week
and a half
so i didn't know what to make of it and
then there was a revelation from jay
glazer that we heard last night he said
they consulted with the texas rangers
baseball staff yeah
it was also the yankees so there was
clearly even more concern about this
thing so when i reached out to some
people uh within the baseball community
they said well this is something that
could be as dramatic as season ending or
it's a cortisone shot so i kind of
stayed away from it because
it's sort of all over the place yeah you
can even see the confusion last night on
the episode just like nobody really knew
what was going on like jerry jones just
bothering the medical staff like
it's really weird okay yeah and then
i would say for cowboy fans that have
to give them a moment of relief
that prescott was out there yesterday
throwing the ball 20 15 yards jamari
cooper off to the side he's just one of
those players and and if i had to guess
that second surgery
and this
are two examples of dak wanting
to be so great and get back on the field
of his teammates that i think
you have to save him from himself
sometimes in other words hey dak don't
push it don't rush it and even as dak
and kellen moore said or mike mccarthy
helen moore said
because we had the hall of fame game we
had the benefit of four preseason games
they got out here early this was a team
that was full participation in mini camp
at otas so they've gotten a lot done i
think the one thing that's probably
lacking at this point is
continuity because we've seen tyron
smith out with elbow tendonitis amore
cooper just got activated off the public
and of course now you've got that
prescott but i don't get the sense
they're overly worried and just
the thing i keep going back to is even
after all that happens the first day
decided practice he came out to the
practice field and still did those
interviews with all the local media at
six pm that night and for a guy that
spent an entire offseason dealing with a
brutal
season-ending injury to come back from
that and then to have a quote-unquote
setback with his arm
if it was gonna be
serious or a true setback i don't think
he would have come out there and done
all those interviews been at practice
you know the next days when he had the
cake to the space like he's been in the
best of spirits and he's gone through
full bore in all of the workouts using
that lower body and throwing just kind
of with the left hand gingerly as he
gets it back to the training staff so
just based on what i see with my eyes
and what i'm being told
it doesn't feel like this is a major
setback so that's all i can that's all i
know and all i can say based on just
what i've seen and heard
at slater nfl on twitter jane slater nfl
network joins the show and jane as you
know the cowboys are probably the most
polarizing franchise in all of sports
you're either a die hard or you hate
them with a passion it seems that nobody
seems to be indifferent to the dallas
cowboys but i have to be honest with you
jane getting to know tj jefferson over
these last few weeks filling in for rich
on the rich eisen show there's part of
my heart that is rooting for the dallas
cowboys the super bowls about a nine
iron from the rich eisen show studios
can you imagine tj jefferson in los
angeles super bowl week with the cowboys
in the big game is there a feeling of
just like specialness around this group
is this a special group you think do you
think tj has real plans
for super bowl celebration here in los
angeles
i think there's real talent on this
roster but to be fair there's been
talent on this roster in years past the
problem with the cowboys is putting it
all together
and whether that be coaching whether
that be injuries
i think just they haven't been able to
put it all together and and
i've been shocked to see even jerry
jones take a more
tempered approach to the season uh mike
mccarthy saying you know last night
you know let me paraphrase because of
all the f-bombs that essentially they're
not there for
a winning season they're not there for
the playoffs they're worth the people
that's the most deliberate
i've heard them talk about this season i
think it's implied
that's why jerry made the change with
mike mccarthy a guy who has skins on the
wall that's why they went all in on
defense they said goodbye to a lot of uh
guys that were free agents spent eight
of their 11 draft picks on defense
and then just how emotional jerry's been
as of late
he's an emotional guy he pulls you in
when he talks about his passion for
football and specifically for this team
but it does feel different this year and
i've said that in the past but i mean
you saw when he's getting really
emotional talking about he could be
anywhere in the world but he chooses
uh to be a training camp
think about anything that you've loved
and anything that you put
your heart and soul into and then just
to have it come up flat every year
i would imagine that's frustrating and i
know a lot of people say well if you're
willing to do anything
to get to a super bowl why don't you
just name
a gm it seems like that's very uniquely
dallas you say i mean mark cuban is
doing that now with the hell is maverick
so
i understand the need to cut out the
middleman and a lot of people don't
realize will mcclay and his and his
staff do a lot of the work but obviously
jerry signs off on all of it and i'm
always very impressed with how
well jerry
knows this team i mean this is a guy
that can literally go down the list and
tell you everything you need to know
about players i've interviewed several
coaches who just know guys by numbers
but he knows the intricacies of all
players so for the knock on that i
understand but just covering this team
i truly believe this team wants to win
but i think given how ugly last season
got and all the optimism when cd lamb
fell to you and it felt like you were
getting all these free agents coming to
dallas because mike mccarthy and it was
disastrous
i think everyone's just being tempered
and maybe that's a good thing for dallas
finally
jane slater joins the show nfl network
ben lyons in for rich on the rich eisen
show hey jane what up it's tj how you
doing what's up my man oh chillin
chillin so i've got a question
i know you've got a lot of good friends
you know and you like to do nice stuff
for your friends whether it be you know
julie sessions or colleen wolfe or mj
acosta you've given love to my friends
of course
of course now here's the question i know
you love them but do you love them
enough to do what
zeke did for dak and give him like a
goyard
bag rolling suitcase that costs i don't
know
i'd say a substantial amount of change i
mean
are you that close with someone that you
spend that kind of coin on a gift does
colleen wolf get that on her upcoming
birthday that's all that's all i'm
asking
it's a great question and i feel like my
social media persona is not in alignment
with what my actual bank account is
sometimes
i know that i know that ben lyons used
to roll in those fancy new york circles
and the vogue circles but i actually
didn't even know what that bag is plug
out the i fly it's a bag you can get at
walmart it's a hard shell it's a hundred
dollars and i fought with some friends
who had the two me bags i'm like it's
just a suitcase
um
but to your point i was thinking the
same thing and almost put a poll out on
twitter last night so i like to see that
you and i are always thinking that
content is key here
i don't think i've ever spent more than
maybe a hundred bucks on a dinner for a
friend we've got this friend group in
dallas and it's fairly obnoxious and i
refuse to participate
it's like 20 girls that i don't even
know
most of them on this group text and
every girl's birthday it's everyone pic
pitching a hundred dollars to buy
someone a fancy bag i don't have half
the fancy bags that these girls have in
fact there's a section of city episode
where sarah jessica parker ended up
sending
uh she registered for shoes because she
kept buying all of her friends baby
shower gifts and wedding gifts and she
was like i just want shoes after all of
this investment so long story short
i can't imagine i think somebody sent me
a link to this it's a thirteen thousand
five hundred dollars it's really
expensive wow
so i've got two thoughts on that too
these days there's a lot of sponsorship
so remember when he got the offensive
line all those john deere uh they were
like razor tractors that that they could
ride
i'm sure he had a hook up there and i've
got to imagine that goyard or whatever
this bag is
got quite a bit of publicity from doing
this so maybe he got a discount he does
have a very good agent in rocky arsenal
i wouldn't put it past him jane slater
joining the show pretending not to know
anything about goal yardbacks
on the rich eisen show
jane uh i saw your your social media i
saw at slater nfl on twitter you
mentioned it and i saw you got a bone to
pick with this show what's the beef
you know i'm disappointed guys i
and sometimes and i'm gonna give you
guys an opportunity to defend yourselves
because sometimes
social media is like phone and stories
get twisted and manipulated but i was
disappointed to hear and read that you
guys thought that i wouldn't survive to
survivors
i'd be voted off the island
who said that
why is that first of all jane i don't
know if on the island of nfl reporters
who have to live off the land to survive
i don't know if that's your natural
environment they don't have 200 flaming
desserts that come on fire on instagram
i am not that boozy
so for sal palantonio somebody who's you
know had to survive off the rest stops
on the i-95 for 30 years
let's talk about sal when you go on a
shoot
i'm going to go with sao paulo i got to
be honest we need to phone a friend and
call my bestie diana rossini to talk
about this rustini and i are like
cockroaches i mean i survived last year
here in dallas and i didn't know if the
cowboys were going to let me come back
after all the times i talked about
defense so if i can survive jerry jones
and the cowboys i think i can survive
uh being on an island of folks i also
grew up in a family contrary to popular
belief on social media this off season
we were in pop-up tents so like my whole
growing up we did a lot of camping i was
in girl scouts
so what is your specialty are you are
you going for the fish are you cooking
the rice are you building the hut like
what would be your niche on survivor
all the things i'm incredibly
resourceful i also am a huge fan of
dystopian dramas and into the world
so everything from the walking dead to
you name it i've watched it and i've
prepared for all of these potential
scenarios
then you know as a fan of the show then
you don't want to be too strong
because then you're a target
well that's why i i am going down the
elizabeth hasselbach track you know she
looks petite and blonde and cute and
everyone said she's not going to make it
it's all in the mind guys all in the
mind jane slater climbing up the power
rankings here on the rich eisen show of
nfl
porter's surviving in the wild don't
know if diana rossini can skin a
squirrel to make it through the night we
appreciate you taking some time jane hey
ben also jane if jane survived that
metairie heat in that tweet
but if you
and almost shut twitter down if you
could survive that james yeah i'm
thinking maybe you could
i support you survive
it's hard out here in these streets
i remember
i remember getting this tweet it was
just like i have no idea where we got
this but i'm so happy
she's already training for our for our
survivor series with nfl reporters we
appreciate the dedication jane climbing
the power rankings thanks for checking
in
bye guys always good talking to you guys
later nfl network giving us great stuff
on the cowboys all right so jane's
climbing the list
power rankings
south pao antonio right at the top that
guy's been surviving
off rest stops and snacks on the i-95
for years i thought we agreed that
florio was from west virginia so he made
it
mario
mario's a sleeper jane slater no not
afraid of the humidity from that tweet
like i got so excited talking to her
about nfl survivor i forgot to get that
nugget about the saints from her she had
like something on the saints
nugget that's right
saints nugget but let's carve a bone to
pick with us that's later nfl on twitter
coming in hot
i don't remember anyone saying that she
would yeah
were we disparaging
no i don't know if albert breer said
that she couldn't build a fort but by
the way i mean i love albert but he's
the first yeah no he's more of a glamper
i can tell
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here